as most of us do you go what am i going
to get them as a gift and i
and i thought i just wanted something
sentimental and a place for
him to have as a bit of a home base with
our son
meghan markle shares the touching
father's day gift she gave prince harry
in her first interview following their
bombshell sit down with oprah winfrey
in an interview with npr weekend edition
on sunday
the duchess of sussex opened up about
her new children's book the bench
which was inspired by the bench she
gifted harry on his first father's day
just weeks after their now two-year-old
son archie was born
you know i often find especially in this
past year i think so many of us
realize how much happens in the quiet
in the story i'm observing this love
between my husband and our son
and imagining what it will be as they
have more shared moments as our son gets
older so from
scraping a knee to having a heart broken
whatever it is that they always reset at
this bench and have this moment to bond
on the back of harry's bench megan wrote
a poem on a plaque
which inspired the children's book it
reads quote
this is your bench where life will begin
for you and our son
our baby our kin
megan and harry are now parents to two
after welcoming their daughter lilibeth
diana earlier this month
let's talk about this for a second in
her interview with npr
megan also touched on the importance of
having other cultures
religions ethnicities and more
represented in the book's illustrations
it's not just black and white you know
growing up i remember
so much how it felt to not see yourself
represented
so any child or any family hopefully can
open this book and see themselves in it
whether that means glasses or freckled
or a different body shape or different
ethnicity
or religion megan went on to emphasize
that she hopes people can see this book
as a love story that transcends the
story of her family
it's really just about growing with
someone and
having this deep connection and this
trust so that
be it good times or bad you know that
you have this person and you know you
can always go back to this place that
you shared together
and i think that really is the larger
message in it ut recently caught up with
royal expert katie nichol
who says there is hope that megan and
harry's new daughter lillabet
will help men the current rift between
the couple and the royal family
well i think everyone's hope is that
this little baby is going to be
a rift healer um because this
family division has really gone on for a
very long time now it's well over a year
it's been many many months since charles
the queen and the cambridges have seen
archie
in the flesh and we know that there have
been some
really quite deep problems between harry
and william
difficulties between harry and his
father and i think it's everyone's
hope that this little baby will will be
a peace offering
in many ways and that she will help to
bring this divided family
back together
you